- That was ridiculous.
- Are you an athlete, Lefkoe?
- Not really.
- Let me see you just
naturally come through
like you got a ball in your hand
right here?
- Not time to panic yet.
- He should probably panic
a little bit.
♪♪♪
[Cheering]
- Let's go! Let's go!
Let's go!
Welcome to
"Simms & Lefkoe: The Show"!
The homies have arrived.
They're havin' a good time
live at Dantanna's in Atlanta.
And Simms.
- Derwin's over here like,
"Look at all you crazy people.
What's goin' on here?"
- We got ourselves
somebody special
an All-Pro safety
in his very first season.
He said, "You're not gonna
take me till 17?
Then I'm gonna smash it
in your face."
Cuz it's Derwin James.
Can I get more for the man?
[Cheering]
- Uh!
- Yes, sir.
What up, man?
- So why is the NFL
so easy to you?
- I mean, it's not easy, man.
- [Laughing]
- It's not easy at all, man,
but it's fun, you know
bein' able to go out there
and make plays on Sunday.
So it's a lot of fun.
- All right, so,
two teams in the Super Bowl
two teams that beat
the Chargers.
Not a lot of teams have beat
the Chargers this year.
And I'm not tryin' to come out
with the negative stuff.
- Oh my God.
- No, but the truth is, is like
you're gonna know these teams
better than any of us.
And I'm curious.
Did you think that these were
two of the best teams you faced?
And what did you learn
about them facing them?
- Yeah, I feel like
those two teams
were two of the best teams
that we faced this year.
I feel like Tom Brady—
They're not gonna wow you
with the athletes and stuff
but I feel like they come out,
execute every game
and they're gonna be
what they need to be.
And then the Rams
they have game-changing players
like Aaron Donald
and Todd Gurley.
So it's two different teams.
But if I had to
pick, I'd say the Patriots win.
- New England whupped you guys
pretty good.
- That was a good whuppin'.
- Yeah, that was a good whuppin'.
- Yeah, a good whuppin'.
But what was
that experience like?
Just, I mean—
- To see that machine.
- The machine.
Go up into Foxborough.
I'm sure they were yellin' a lot
of creative stuff at you guys.
- Yeah.
- And did you get, like,
in awe of Brady or them at all
throughout the game?
- I mean, goin' against Brady,
it was fun
cuz like I said,
they came out
they had a good game plan,
they executed.
And we didn't come out
and play in the first half
and then we got down too far.
And, like I say,
you're not gonna come back
once he gets a lead on you
like that.
- Are you the most famous James
in L.A—
- Who, me?
- Playing sports?
- [Laughing]
- I might be, man.
Hey, I might be.
I don't know.
But King James
we got a good race
goin' right now.
- All right.
- So, I was watching, like
your IG and stuff
from the Pro Bowl
and I'm seeing all these
great players on the field.
I'm seeing, like,
you and Keenan Allen
and Jalen Ramsey.
And I'm curious,
if you could make
Derwin James' best secondary
two corners, another safety,
and you
who would be your—
and not including Chargers.
So we don't—
Sorry, teammates.
- No Chargers?
- No Chargers.
Who would be
your ultimate secondary?
- I say Jalen at one corner.
I'd have to go Patrick Peterson
probably at another corner.
And I'd put me and Jamal
back there.
- Jamal Adams.
- The two 33s back there.
- Yeah, 33s back there.
- Is there—
cuz I feel like you guys
you're gonna be competing
for All-Pro spots
and all that.
But I feel like you guys
play so similar.
Is there, like,
a friendship there too?
- Yeah, we got
a great friendship.
I mean, we've grown
over the last year
of knowing each other.
We respect each other game
and I feel like
he gonna do great things
and I'm gonna do great things
in this league.
- We have a number
of meaningless debates
that I would like you
to help us settle.
I don't know
what side you're on.
I don't even know
what side I'm on.
Waffle House at 2 p.m.
or 2 a.m.?
- A.M.
- Yeah! A.M.!
- A.M., come on. A.M.!
- I'm just sayin' this right now.
- Waffle House for the game!
- I kinda feel grimy
when I go there at 2 p.m.
- Yeah.
- I agree.
- Right?
I'm like, "Ugh!
2 p.m. Waffle House?!"
- Oh, you trippin'.
- "What the hell
am I doin' in here?"
- My girlfriend has never—
- 2 in the morning, man
you good.
- My girlfriend's never been
to a Waffle House
and she would go at 2 p.m.
You don't wanna see it.
You don't want the sun comin' in
and see what the floors
look like.
- Nah, nah.
- No.
This is a debate that we have
had on the podcast forever.
If there was a fight
between a grizzly bear
and a lion
who would win that fight?
- A lion.
- A lion?
So you're Team Simms.
I believe that the bear—
- Why?
- Would destroy the lion.
- Because the lion can only
attack straightforward.
And even if he bites the bear
you have the monster bear claws
comin' down.
He can tear him apart.
- But we have seen video—
- Yes.
- That the lion has
a hard time with the bear.
It hurt my heart.
- Yes.
- I watched it,
I had to put it down.
I was like, "I can't see this.
- Yes.
- It's hurting me."
- For real.
- Yeah.
- It's been well-documented.
- Because, like,
the lion is so muscular
he fatigues out.
And the bear's so thick and fat,
it doesn't bother him.
- The bear is like Fletcher Cox
and the lion
is like Derwin James.
- Derwin James, right.
- Eventually, he's gonna go,
"Are you done?"
- [Laughing]
- I ain't gonna get tired.
- So, OK, new battle
Derwin James, Fletcher Cox.
- [Laughing]
- Yeah, that's better, yeah.
- How would you do?
- I'mma do good.
- How many Fletcher Coxes—
- I like me.
how many Adam Lefkoes
would it take
to beat up Fletcher Cox?
- How many?
- How many of me would—
- They don't got enough,
I don't feel like.
[Laughing]
They don't make enough.
- Four?
- No.
- OK.
- I don't think four would do it.
- No, obviously not.
- I think five, maybe.
- I think 12
is the number I was thinking.
- I think if we had
one Lefkoe on each limb
and then a fifth one
to finally go to the body
and the head—
- No.
- You'd have a chance.
- You're overestimating me,
very much.
All right, can we get
a round of applause
for Derwin James, please?
[Cheering]
- Thank y'all, man.
- You're the man.
- Appreciate y'all, man, for sure.
- Good luck to you, keep it goin'.
- Yes, sir.
- I'm J.J. Watt
and ou're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe"
[Cheering]
- More, more, more,
more, more, more, more!
Ohh!
Feels so good.
The homies, the homies,
the homies.
All right, well,
we gotta talk about the game.
- Yeah.
- Sunday.
- Yes.
- Patriots-Rams.
I've never sat
this far from you. Feels weird.
- I know,
we are really far.
- What's goin' on over there?
- [Laughing]
- So, the line,
according to Caesar's—
arguably the best casino
I've ever seen
in my entire life—
is Patriots by 2.5.
I wanna know
your last thoughts
going into the game
to aid my pick for this game.
- Right off the bat,
if you win the toss
don't make the same mistake
Andy Reid made, right
which was he deferred
and kicked it
to Tom Brady and company.
Don't let New England—
don't let the train get rolling.
That would be the first thing
I would say.
If I'm the Rams,
I am gonna take the ball.
You might go three-and-out,
whatever
maybe only a first down
but your defense
is gonna get on the sideline.
They're gonna be able
to get geared up a little bit.
And I would just worry about
if you let Brady
and the New England machine
and all their game-planning
come out the first drive
and just,
"Oh gosh, here it goes."
It's pulling guards.
It's screens.
It's Brady down the middle.
- And then the whole air
leaves the stadium.
- The air leaves the stadium.
- Cuz everyone's goin',
"Here's Tom Brady."
- And the Rams are gonna go
"Damn, this is, uh—
we haven't seen this.
I guess this is the Patriots."
And I worry about that aspect.
- And your big thing
if the Rams
wanna have a chance
is they have to set up
on defense right away.
- Yes,
that's one of my big issues
with the Rams
in the Saints game.
And it's been an issue
for them all year.
And I know
and Lefkoe pointed this out
with my notes last week
when the Patriots
see a flaw like that
and they start
to go through a game
and they go, "Man, there was
60 snaps in this game
and about 25 of them
the Rams were still
talking to each other
when the snap was going on"
New England is going to have
a package of plays—
- They did that to Tennessee
in the playoffs last year.
- Exactly right.
Where they just say one word.
Like, I say, it might be
"tequila," all right.
- Ooh, hey.
- And they're gonna say "Tequila"
and they're gonna know
the formation to line up in
the play they're running
and there's gonna be no talk
and it's gonna be
get up there quick
and Brady's just gonna
hit the guy in the butt
and they're gonna
snap it and go.
And all the sudden
the Rams are gonna be
all flustered.
And if they feel like
they get a little success there
they're gonna keep
continuing to do that.
So those are little things
I watch early.
The Rams gotta keep it close
early.
- It gets away, yeah.
- If it goes 10-nothing first quarter,
night-night.
They're in trouble.
But if we get through
the first quarter
and it's 6-3, 7-3—
- Yeah.
- You know, anywhere in that range
then the Rams, I think,
got a chance.
The Rams gotta get some stops
early on
because if they are
on the field too much
you guys have heard me—
- Yeah.
- I worry that the thinness
of their roster hurts them.
- All right, talk about
the Caesar's line.
We had a big competition.
Can Adam Lefkoe,
the legend that he is
throw the ball 50 yards?
Vegas set the line at 50 yards.
You said "over."
And then I think you went out
there and you took the under.
- Well, I thought you could get
very close
and I thought he would get it
But as I got here
Super Bowl week
I was like, "You know,
this is gonna be more fun
if he doesn't get it
so I'm gonna root against him."
So let's go!
Let's get into it!
- All right, so here it is.
For the first time,
I reveal the 50-yard challenge.
Oh my gosh.
[Cheering]
So everyone comes to media day
and they make it
about themselves
and they make jokes.
We have credentials.
- Yes, we are big-time.
- Serious journalism.
- Yes, official.
- And we're here to see
if the Rams and Patriots believe
I can throw the ball 50 yards.
- Ohh!
♪♪♪
- Here with Johnny Hekker
who is kinda
known for your arm
more than your leg
these days.
- The best-throwing punter
I've ever seen.
- Wow, touch that!
- Damn! Damn!
- I flexed a little bit.
- Whoo!
- So we were doin' a pod,
and he looked at me and he went
"Lefkoe, I think
you can throw it 50 yards."
- Gimme a throw. Try.
- Like—
That's all I'm gonna give you
is that motion.
- I think he can.
- That's a good endorsement
right there.
- Yeah, I think he can do it.
- That's big.
- I believe in you.
- 50 yards?
- 50 yards.
- Running start?
- Crow hop.
- Yeah, he can do
whatever he wants.
- Whatever he wants?
- He can do a somersault.
- I think you could get it.
- Damn!
- I don't like—
I don't think so.
- You don't think so, either?
- 50 yards is not easy.
- No.
- If you looked
a little more like Brady
and my man Chris here, maybe.
But you're too—
you know what it is?
You got too many muscles.
- He's too squatty.
He has gotta—
he thinks he can
throw the ball 50 yards.
We just want—you think he can?
Size him up.
- No.
- Just that quick?
- No! End it!
Do you think
he can throw it 50?
- I'll give him 50.
- You gonna look in his eye
and say that?
Damn, OK.
Look at that motion.
Do you think he can throw it
50 yards, Marcus Peters?
- That was serious.
- It's a different stroke
for every folk
so, I don't know.
How many you got back there?
- What do you think?
Hekker said yes.
C.J. said no.
- 50?
- 50 yards.
- I got you to the 35.
- 35!
- He's not throwing that ball
50 yards.
- Yeah!
- You don't think so?
- No.
- He thinks he can
throw the ball 50 yards.
- Ain't no way.
- No way.
- What?
- Ain't no way!
- Ain't no way.
- He just looked—
- Ain't no way!
- You ever play quarterback?
- Like, with my friends.
- No chance.
- No chance. Thank you.
- Damn!
- What advice would you give me?
- Don't overgrip the ball.
- OK.
- That's a good one.
- Don't overgrip it.
- Right.
- Don't overstride.
- Yeah.
- You can launch it.
- If you get some air,
you might get some carry.
- You might get some wind or—
- If you have the wrong
trajectory, I don't know.
- Are you an athlete, Lefkoe?
- Not really.
- Let me see you
just naturally come through
like you got a ball in your hand
right here.
- All right, hold on.
So if I was like—
- You just went to catch it.
No chance you're throwin' it 50.
♪♪♪
- I mean, 50 yards.
It's far.
Don't overthrow your first one.
♪♪♪
OK, Lefkoe.
45.
- Damn.
♪♪♪
- We're about 47-ish.
Those last three or four yards
are very hard to get.
- I'm channeling
my inner Nick Foles.
No one can explain it.
It's magic.
Sometimes magic happens.
Ah, s--t!
♪♪♪
Damn! Not that time.
- Wow!
48 yards!
♪♪♪
- [Sighing] 48.
I mean,
I guess I'm getting more.
Ugh!
Vegas always knows
where to set the line
don't they?
- They really do.
♪♪♪
No!
- 30 yards is your low
of the day.
Not time to panic yet.
He should probably panic
a little bit.
♪♪♪
- What was that?
- 49.
- Are you kidding?!
- So close.
Want to touch the 50.
♪♪♪
I think that's all she wrote.
- S--t.
And now my arm's thrown out.
My arm's dead.
♪♪♪
- That was a good try.
- Dang it.
- It really was.
It was so close.
I mean, you got to 49.
You got to 40—
I'm not even gonna lie.
I really didn't think
you were even gonna get there
once I saw you warm up.
- I tried.
I thought I had it.
But I guess I'm a 49 man.
I'm just, you know—
- Yeah.
- That's what I'm capable of.
♪♪♪
- Oh, man!
- I'm just gonna tell you guys.
To get to 49 is, like,
the most bittersweet thing ever
so much so that I thought
he was lying
about the half a yard.
- He really was.
He was like, "Are you lying?!"
And I was like,
"I would not cheat you."
- I appreciate you guys.
I know you supported me.
So thank you for helping me
try to get to 50.
- Yo, way to go, Lefkoe.
You're a good sport, man.
No joke.
- So next up, two guys
that could definitely
throw the ball 50 yards.
Two guys that think they're
better football friends than us.
- Never.
- Chad Johnson and Terrell Owens.
- Never!
- So you guys know
that when it comes
to Best Football Friends
Simms and myself believe that
we are the cream of the crop
and we've looked
all over the NFL
to see who can compete
with this connection.
- Nobody!
- But we found two guys that
wanna take the test, Simms.
- Ugh!
How dare they?
- Why don't you introduce them?
- You mean Bjorn
the German DJ over there?
- Yes!
- Chad Ochocinco?
- Chad Johnson.
- Bjorn the German DJ,
techno DJ.
- No, you know what, I'm taking over.
My name is Tommy Shelby.
- Tommy Shelby, apparently,
and we have
the Hall of Famer Terrell Owens.
Terrell Owens!
Terrell!
- Yeah, give 'em some applause.
- How you guys doin'?
- So here's how this
is gonna work.
We have a lot of competitions
to see
whose connection is stronger.
Not only that,
we also have the referee
from the end
of the Rams-Saints game
that decided
not to throw the flag.
I'm only kidding.
It is our referee
for "Simms & Lefkoe."
- Go easy.
Go easy, all right?
Look, you guys weren't there.
There was a guy in the front row
making a hilarious face
and I'm easily distracted,
all right?
So just go easy.
- Awesome.
- He will be the arbiter to see
who is right, who is wrong.
This is gonna get
very competitive.
- Watch these two, ref.
- I would say we could bring
Roger Goodell in this situation
but he's of no use.
- No comment.
- Oh, that got a lot of "oohs."
- I'm just saying.
- Are you guys ready?
You got your game faces on?
- Yeah, I'm just waiting
for the "Jeopardy" tune.
- Here we go.
In what year did Chad lead
the NFL in receiving yards?
- Wow. Congratulations.
- What year?
- I don't even know
if Chad remembers.
- Don't look at each other.
Stay focused on the whiteboard.
- Don't look at each other!
- Write down your answer.
- We don't have multiple choice?
- I don't even remember.
No hints?
- No hints.
- Write down your year.
Stop cheating.
Enough of this.
- No, I don't even remember.
I swear to God, I promise.
- Yeah,
so write down a year.
- Go ahead.
- When you're good
we don't keep up
with stats like that, bro.
- Ohh, yes.
- I'm just sayin'.
- I think I can lead
the league right now.
- Right.
- With these damn rules.
All right, never mind.
- No looking,
no looking.
Turn your stuff.
- Flip 'em.
It is 2006!
- Are you serious?!
- Nailed it!
- It is?
- Ohh!
- It was?
- 2006!
- That is ridiculous!
- That's my dawg!
- What?!
- That was some telepathic stuff
right there.
- That's my dawg!
- What is T.O.'s middle name?
- Ooh, I love this one.
- Well, we expect you to know.
Don't tell him.
- He has to know.
- Yeah.
- What?!
- Did you see Terrell?
Terrell's like,
"Yo, that's easy.
I already know my own middle name."
- What is his middle name?
- And it's not "Handsome."
Just FYI.
It's not "Handsome."
- Wait a minute.
We haven't gotten that far
in our relationship.
- That's why you're not gonna be
the Best Football Friends, Chad.
- If he gets this, dawg,
I'mma fall out.
- All right, Chad.
Flip it.
- I went with what makes sense
to me, and it flows, you know.
So if I was his mom,
this is what I would've named him.
- Hold on, dawg, hold on.
- You ready?
- Yeah.
- Three, two, one.
Flip 'em.
- Edward.
He does look like
he's got a little Edward.
- So here's the deal.
- That makes sense, though.
- Edward?!
- You got the first letter right.
- You got the first letter.
- Terrell's middle name
is Eldorado.
- What?!
- Yes.
- Like the furniture store?!
- No. Like the car!
- Like the car.
- Can we put, like,
an asterisk by that?
Because there's no way
I would have known
his name was Eldorado.
- Well, if you have a middle name
like that
you should have known that.
That's, like, "Eldorado?"
- There's a reason
he didn't tell me
cuz I would have
still been making fun of him.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- Eldorado?
- You have a point, you have a point.
Now the f--king
whole world knows.
- Eldorado!
I'm never gonna call you
T.O. ever again.
- Eldorado?
- Another T.O. question.
What college did T.O. attend?
- Oh!
What I'm talkin' about, man!
This is what relationships
are about!
- Here we go.
Three, two, one!
Flip 'em!
- Something.
Some train—Chatta-something.
Whatever.
- Here we go.
Back to a T.O. question.
How many career
TDs did T.O. have, within 10?
- I mean, I know right off
the top of my head.
- Really?
- Well, then write it down.
- Write it down.
- 153.
Within 10, correct!
- Ohh!
- You shorted him two touchdowns.
- I did?
- Yeah.
- That's all right.
- You know what, they should have been mine.
That's what it was. They should have been mine.
- You got it right.
It was within 10.
- He can borrow a couple.
- Are you gentlemen ready
to defend your house?
- We are ready.
- Are you kidding? Born this way.
- All right, here we go.
Starting off with
a Lefkoe question.
What popular diet did Lefkoe do
for 30 days
in the summer of 2017?
- Wow.
- Ohh!
I'm not sure about this
but I think I got him pegged
for what he would do.
- It was the vegan diet.
- What did he say?
- I voted Atkins.
- Oh yeah, you guys really starting off
on the right foot!
- Who?
- Atkins diet.
It's, like, a meat-only diet.
- I don't think someone's done
the Atkins diet
in like 15 years.
- You're crazy.
There's lots of people
that do the Atkins diet.
- Hey, hey, you guys argue
about it later.
- I never even heard
about that before.
- You did a vegan diet?
- Yes, I talked about it
on the podcast.
- Damn, I don't remember that.
- Clearly, he wasn't listening.
- Apparently not, Eldorado.
- Damn!
- Hey, you can be mad at me.
- Sorry, sorry, sorry.
- You need to be gettin' mad at him.
- I got emotional.
- Exactly. Clearly.
- Damn!
- He's the one got it wrong.
- Damn it, man. I'm sorry.
- Who is Simms'
favorite female singer?
- Ohh!
- Oh!
- You know this, buddy.
- I do. I do. I do.
- Just concentrate.
- All right, hold on.
- Jessica Simpson?
- Concentrate.
- Faith Hill?
- No.
- Nope.
- You two, I don't think
are even gonna know
who this person is.
- Oh, um...Miranda Lambert.
Flip 'em!
You got it right!
- Yeah!
Lana, yeah. Way to go.
Thanks, friend.
- Gotcha.
- Well done.
- I'm happy to carry
this team yet again, Simms.
- What was Simms'
highest Madden rating?
- Ha ha ha!
- I'm not even sure
I know this one.
Damn, what do I think I was?
- If I get this right
and he gets this wrong—
- Gosh. Damn.
- We have a serious problem.
- Well, I stopped playing
once I got in the game
cuz I didn't wanna do it anymore.
- It's in the game.
- Let's see where we got 'em.
Three, two, one!
It was 84!
- Whoo!
- Damn!
- I'm not gonna lie.
There was a time
where I drafted Chris Simms
in one of the leagues on Madden.
- Did you really?
- But for cap concerns,
I had to cut you.
- Ohh.
- What is Lefkoe's birthday?
- Ooh!
- I had a feeling!
- All right, so,
if you've watched this show
Simms is 0-for-2
on this discussion.
- I'm 0-for-2 on his birthday.
OK?
- Yeah.
You nailed it!
- Hey, best friend.
- Proud of you.
- How you doin', best friend?
- It's all tied up at 3.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
- Yeah!
- Look, there's only one way
to settle this, guys—
- Race!
- And that is a tiebreaker.
Gentlemen.
Jenga. You're first.
- Wait, first of all.
What are you—you got, like—
you doin' finger
exercises over here?
- Absolutely.
- What the hell is this?
- I'm always prepared.
See, I didn't even know this,
but I'm always prepared.
- That's not good for this.
That means you're gonna
have heavy fingers.
- That's OK. We'll see.
- They're gonna be too strong.
- Who's first? Us?
- You're first.
- Yeah, you're first.
- OK.
Cool. We'll go.
- Hey, wait.
I wanna go first.
We'll Paper-Rock-Scissors
for who goes first.
- OK, cool.
- One, two, three.
- Oh!
- Damn!
Go ahead.
- That's what I thought.
- Just touch all of them, T.
- And it is one hand, right?
- Yes.
Oh, it could end right here.
- Oh, it could end right here.
- It's gonna end right here.
- Ohh! Ohh!
- I mean, this is insane.
- I told you those exercises
weren't gonna help in this game.
- Ohh!
- [Laughing]
- Come on!
- Never has it been easier
to figure out
who the Best
Football Friends are.
- Hey!
Hey! Hey, hey, hey, hey!
- Easy! Easy.
Easy! No, no, no!
- Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa!
- This isn't happening.
- Wow!
- You think you're the champion?!
- We run this!
- What?!
- Are you kidding me?
- Quality time!
We are here.
You guys lost to these guys?
- And there's a belt.
Guys, this is Trent Taylor
and George Kittle
of the San Francisco 49ers.
- What are you talking about?
- T.O.! Ochocinco!
- What's up?
- They beat us
in Best Football Friends.
- What's up,
you little crap, you?
- I heard these dudes
were out here
acting like they were
the best friends in football
or something like that.
I don't know.
- Damn!
- Wow!
- You OK?
- Yeah, I'm good.
I'm just gonna be honest.
I'm really intimidated.
- You should be.
- Wait, so, what happens?
Now are you gonna face us?
- Yeah, they wanna face us.
- No, we already beat you guys.
- We're not scared
of anything, honestly.
- This ain't no round robin.
- This is our house.
You came into our house.
We're getting a rematch.
Sorry.
- We did beat you already,
but we're not
scared of anything.
- Easy, Mini-Me.
Easy.
- Should we go for a rematch
against Kittle and Trent Taylor?
I need to hear some noise.
- We already whupped on 'em.
- Wow!
We're gonna let
the champions go first.
- Ooh!
- Oh!
- Kittle's a middle guy.
- He's looking at
the second level.
- You're good.
It's sturdy.
- They say he likes
to play the slot—
- I don't like that.
- But he's pulling
from the outside.
- Stop. Stop.
Holy cow.
- Wow.
Wiggle it!
Just a little bit.
- Oh, dear.
- Pull it! Pull it!
- Is it moving up top?
- You're good.
- Pull it! Pull it!
Ohh!
- Ahh!
- No!
- Ah!
- The title goes back—
- It's back at home!
- To Simms and Lefkoe!
- Oh, it's back at home!
Yeah!
It knew its proper place!
- I'm still takin' the belt.
- And what do you know?
Proving yet again
that Simms and Lefkoe
are the Best Football Friends.
For George Kittle,
for Trent Taylor
for all the homies
in Dantanna's
thank you guys so much!
- It's all ours, honey.
- Simms and Lefkoe back again!
- Prevail!
- Thank you. guys.
Enjoy the Super Bowl.
- We're like the Patriots.
We might lose in Week 1,
but when it really counts—
- That's all that matters.
- I think that I'm winning
- One more round of applause for
Trent and George for coming out.
- Thanks for coming.
- Thanks guys.
- Awesome.
- Thanks for having us.
- You guys are awesome.
Good luck with everything.
- Thank you guys.